ahora que ya tenemos un conocimiento más
o menos decente sobre el teorema del
sándwich lo vamos a usar para probar que
el límite lo voy a escribir en amarillo
límite
cuando x tiende a 0 de seno de x / x va
a ser igual a 1 y deben estar temblando
de la anticipación porque ya he
mencionado esto muchas veces y ahora
vamos a hacerlo obviamente ustedes ya
han tomado trigonometría y tenemos la
prueba visual así que permítanme dibujar
al menos el primero y cuarto cuadrante
de nuestro círculo unitario y lo vamos a
dibujar en la gente y déjenme calcular
por dónde porque lo tengo que dibujar
bastante grande vamos a ver vamos a ver
por dónde por donde aquí ok
muy bien aquí está el círculo y ahora
vamos a dibujar los ejes el eje y en
amarillo más o menos
ahí va
el eje x también en amarillo y ese va
por acá
y ese es nuestro círculo unitario muy
bien
ahora necesito dibujar un par de cosas
más vamos a dibujar el radio pero voy a
salir del círculo el radio lo dejo en
verde y vamos a menos hasta por acá
tengo que dibujar a otras cosas más para
resolver este problema
no esto lo vamos a quitar lo vamos a
hacer aquí aquí es donde debe de ir
y otra línea a partir de este punto aquí
el eje derechito muy bien
y tengo que dibujar otra línea de este
punto a este y bye bye bye listo
dijimos que este era nuestro círculo
unitario y esto qué significa bueno es
un círculo cuyo radio es de una unidad
así que la distancia de aquí acá es 1 y
si este es un ángulo x en radiales
x cuál va a ser la longitud de esta
línea de acá bueno por definición el
seno de x se define como la coordenada
de cualquier punto en nuestro círculo
unitario así que esto es seno de x
escribirlo más o menos vamos a señalar
lo mejor con una flecha
esto se lo dé
y déjenme hacerles una pregunta un poco
más difícil
cuál es la longitud de esta línea de acá
cuál es la longitud de aquí bueno vamos
a pensar en ello que es la tangente
vamos a regresar a nuestras definiciones
de zocato a nuestra definición de
tangente es igual
o algo puesto entre el adyacente por o
sexto a tangente igual a opuesto sobre
el yacente y cuál es la tangente de x
bueno viendo el triángulo podemos decir
que este es el ángulo recto es el
triángulo rectángulo sería esta longitud
la opuesta a nuestro ángulo entre la
adyacente así que esto es igual a vamos
a llamar esta línea o de opuesto y cuál
es el valor de esta línea decente bueno
recordemos que este círculo es unitario
así que este valor de aquí es 1
finalmente es el valor de un radio
esto vale 1 así que el opuesto entre el
adyacente que significa la tangente de x
opuesto entre el decente pues es opuesto
entre 1 así que el lado opuesto va a ser
igual a la tangente de x otra forma de
decirlo es que tangente de x es igual a
este lado de acá al lado opuesto vamos a
escribir esto
este lado es igual a la tangente de x
pensemos en el área de estas dos partes
de aquí que dibuje que quizás debía
haberlas dibujado un poco más grandes
pero bueno creo que podremos lograrlo
con esto permíteme escoger este
triángulo que es relativamente pequeño
lo voy a subrayar con verde este
triángulo que vamos a usar este que
estoy trazando en verde
cuál es el área de este triángulo bueno
esto es la mitad de la base por la
altura así que es la mitad un medio
de la base que es uno
todo este triángulo de aquí y cuál es la
altura bueno pues ya calculamos que esta
altura va a ser
el seno de x así que es un medio por uno
por seno de x y este es el triángulo
verde
ahora cuál es el área no de este
triángulo verde sino de esta rebanada
del círculo que voy a dibujar aquí vamos
a ver de qué color para que resalte
vamos a ver en rojo cuál es el área de
este esta rebanada de país
no nos está resultando muy bien vamos a
cambiar de color ahora voy a poner este
color claro estoy resaltando el arco que
es un poquito más grande que el
triángulo en verde ya que incluye esta
pequeña fracción esta pequeña área cuál
es el área de ese arco bueno si este
ángulo es x
en radiales x en radiales de fracción de
esto es con respecto a todo el círculo
entero sabemos que hay dos radiales en
un círculo así que esta área de aquí va
a ser igual a que bueno esto va a ser
igual
a la fracción que representa este x con
respecto
a los dos radiales de este círculo
unitario
x entre 2 por pi y recordamos que esta
es la fracción de esta rebanada amarilla
que estoy indicando aquí si habláramos
de grados esta sería una fracción con
respecto a los 360 grados de todo el
círculo y cuál es el área de todo el
círculo lo multiplicamos por recordemos
que el área es pi por radio al cuadrado
el radio es 1 y el área por lo tanto de
todo el círculo va a ser solamente pi
entonces el área de esta rebanada de
esta fracción de aquí va a ser igual a
estos dos pisos se cancelan y nos queda
x entre 2 así que este primer triángulo
verde en este triángulo pequeño que
habíamos dibujado es seno de x la mitad
de seno de x ese es el área de ese
triángulo verde y el área que es un
poquito más grande de esta rebanada
acabamos de encontrar que es x entre 2 y
ahora vamos a encontrar el área del
triángulo más grande bueno del área del
triángulo es
un medio de la base por la altura un
medio la base es 1 por la altura y vemos
que la altura es tangente de x y esto es
igual a la mitad de la tangente de x
no debería quedar claro viendo el
diagrama que no importa donde dibuje yo
esta línea de aquí arriba ese triángulo
verde va a tener un área más pequeña que
esta rebanada y que también tendrá un
área menor que este triángulo grande
vamos a encontrar una desigualdad que
diga esto el triángulo verde el área de
este triángulo es una mitad de seno
de x el área del triángulo verde
es menor que
el área de esta rebanada que es x / 2
y ambos son menores que este triángulo
grande el área del triángulo grande que
es la mitad de la tangente de x
y esto cuando se cumple cuando es verdad
bueno esto se cumple siempre y cuando
estemos en el primer cuadrante y también
es casi verdad en el cuarto cuadrante la
decisión de que el seno de x se vuelve
negativo y también la tangente de x se
vuelve negativa y también x se volvería
negativo pero el valor absoluto de todo
se conservaría ya que no importa que
estemos tomando valores negativos
siempre y cuando que tengamos los
valores absolutos
tendremos áreas positivas pero bueno mi
meta es encontrar el límite
conforme x se aproxima a 0 y quiero
tomar el límite de manera que esté
definido en general tanto para el lado
positivo como negativo así que vamos a
tomar el valor absoluto en ambos lados
aquí dibujaría una línea y aquí dibujaré
otra que será la tangente de x y
mientras tengamos los valores absolutos
de todo
esencialmente estaremos haciendo lo
mismo que lo que hicimos en este primer
cuadrante así que tomamos el valor
absoluto de todo y esto no debe de
cambiar absolutamente nada especialmente
si estamos en el primer cuadrante así
que tenemos esta desigualdad vamos a ver
si podemos jugar con ella bueno ahora
vamos a multiplicar todos
2 para deshacernos de estos medios nos
queda
el valor absoluto de seno de x
es menor que el valor absoluto de x que
es menor que el valor absoluto de
tangente de x aquí no se confundan con
lo de los valores absolutos la
desigualdad que escribió originalmente
es completamente válida para el primer
cuadrante pero ya que quiero que esto
sea válido en el primero y el cuarto
cuadrante tengo que trabajar con los
valores absolutos para que esto se
cumpla ustedes podrían dibujar la línea
aquí abajo y hacer todo exactamente como
lo hicimos aquí arriba en el cuadrante
de abajo pero si ustedes toman el valor
absoluto debe ser exactamente lo mismo
que en el primer cuadrante bueno
regresemos al problema me estoy dando
cuenta que me estoy quedando sin espacio
así que vamos a limpiar un poco esto
vamos a borrar que ahorraremos que
borraremos
que no es tono
vamos a borrar esto de aquí hasta acá ok
pero esto no nos debemos olvidar eso
también lo borramos y ya tenemos espacio
para trabajar
vamos a tomar esto y dividir todos los
lados
se escucha un poco raro pero tiene tres
lados de la izquierda de enmedio y el de
la derecha y vamos a dividirlos todos
entre seno de x y ya que sabemos que el
valor absoluto del seno de x es un valor
positivo
sabemos que estos símbolos de menor que
no van a cambiar el valor absoluto de
seno de x entre el valor absoluto de
seno de x va a ser igual a 1
aquí escribimos 1 que es menor que el
valor absoluto de x entre el valor
absoluto de seno de x seno de x que a su
vez es menor que cuál es el valor
absoluto de tangente de x lo que soy
haciendo aquí como les digo es dividir
todo entre el valor absoluto de seno de
x aquí acá también cuál es este valor
absoluto de tangente de x entre el seno
de x recordemos que la tangente es el
coseno entre el semma perón ese seno
sobre el coseno así que esto va a ser
igual esta parte de aquí solamente si
bueno el seno entre el coseno que a su
vez está dividido entre el seno y
recordemos que todos estos son valores
absolutos y bueno que es lo que nos
queda pues nos queda uno entre ya que
estos senos se cancelan
este se comete en 1 1 entre el valor
absoluto del coseno de x 1 entre el
valor absoluto de coseno de x y podemos
intuir que ya nos estamos acercando ya
que esto luce bastante similar a esto
solo que está invertido pero para llegar
a esto pues vamos a invertirlo para
invertir lo bueno que va a suceder qué
es lo que pasa cuando se invierte 1
bueno 1 entre 1 sigue siendo 1 así que
aquí sigue siendo 1 cuando invertimos
ambos lados de esta desigualdad tenemos
que cambiar los signos de desigualdad si
esto no les suena muy familiar
recordemos que bueno si yo tengo un
medio que es menor a 2 y si quiero
invertir estos lados tendré que 2 es
mayor que un medio así que barack o
espero que con eso se aclare cuando yo
estoy invirtiendo todos los lados de
esta desigualdad tengo que cambiar los
signos de desigualdad aquí nos queda uno
que es mayor que el valor absoluto de
seno
entre el valor absoluto de x que es
mayor que el valor absoluto de cosenos
de x
ahora permítanme hacerles una pregunta
el valor absoluto de seno de x o
podríamos decir será de x / x llegará un
momento en el que seno de x / x en el
primer y cuarto cuadrante
llegará un momento en el que seno de x
entre x sea una expresión negativa bueno
en el primer cuadrante el seno de x es
positivo y x también es positivo
positivo / positivo va a dar un valor
positivo y en el cuarto cuadrante el
seno de x es negativo el seno de x va a
ser negativo
también el ángulo va a ser negativo así
que en este cuarto cuadrante un número
negativo entre otro número negativo va a
dar un número positivo de esta manera
vemos que siempre el seno de x / x va a
tener un valor positivo así que estos
símbolos de valor absoluto son un poco
redundantes podemos escribir que 1 es
mayor que el seno de x / x y lo mismo
aplica para este terminal
estamos trabajando con menos pi entre 2
es menor que x
que a su vez es menor que pie entre 2
todo esto es desde menos pie entre 2
hasta pie entre 2 en los cuadrantes
primero y cuarto el coste no de x en
algún momento es negativo
sabemos que el pse no va a ser el valor
x que es positivo en estos dos
cuadrantes el valor de x siempre es
positivo y lo mismo si siempre es
positivo pues podemos quitar los
símbolos de valor absoluto y que rico ya
estamos listos para usar el teorema del
sándwich y ahora permite borrar todo
esto de aquí abajo ahora sí ya lo
podemos quitar y ahora déjenme hacerles
otra pregunta cuál es
límite cuando x tiende a 0
en la función 1 bueno la función uno
siempre va a ser igual a 1 así que esto
no importa que pase con la equis si es a
0 o si se va al infinito el límite
siempre va a ser igual a 1 así que
conforme x se aproxima 0 esto se
mantiene en 1 y cuál va a ser el límite
conforme x se aproxima a cero del coseno
de x ella es muy fácil conforme que se
aproxima 0 el consejo de x va a ser 1
así que el límite va a ser 1 y bueno ya
estamos listos para usar el teorema del
sandwich conforme nos aproximamos a 0
conforme x se aproxima a 0 esta función
se aproxima a 1 y esta también se
aproxima a 1 y esta expresión está entre
estas dos expresiones y si está entre
ambas está o se aproxima aún no conforme
nosotros nos aproximamos a cero o
conforme x se aproxima a cero esta otra
también se aproxima a un no conforme x
se aproxima a cero y si ésta está entre
ambas pues también tendrá que estar
tendiendo a uno conforme x tiende a cero
y aquí se cumple el sándwich ya que si
esto se cumple entonces lo de medio
también tendrá que ser verdadero el
límite conforme x tiende a cero va a ser
igual a 1 así que espero que esto les
haya dado la explicación de lo que
queremos probar en un principio
conforman esta línea se va haciendo más
pequeña y más pequeña conforme se
aproxima a cero estas áreas
estas dos van a converger estas áreas
que están en medio tienen que converger
y si quieren ver esto gráficamente
podemos graficar lo acá vamos a ver si
puedo hacer la gráfica con mi excelente
calculadora para que ustedes me crean si
decimos
que uno siempre es mayor que ese 9 x / x
y que siempre va a ser más grande que el
seno de x entre el rango de menos
cliente 2 hasta entre 2 así que podemos
calcular el límite y aquí lo tenemos
esta línea azul de aquí
esa es la función 1 donde es igual a 1
esta línea azul claro de aquí es co 0 de
x y esa es la gráfica de seno de x / x
aquí están aquí los pueden ver que las
teclea así que será de x / x está del
rango perdón de menos pie entre 2 hasta
pie entre 2 o lo que es lo mismo entre
el primero y el cuarto cuadrante la
línea roja siempre va a estar entre
estas otras dos líneas entre la línea
azul oscuro y la línea azul claro así
que esto les puede dar una idea de qué
pasa cuando ambas funciones se comienzan
a hacer sándwiches a la de media esta
línea azul claro se aproxima a 1 y
sabemos que el límite de esta línea
superior azul oscuro va a también ser 1
así que como esta línea siempre está en
medio pues la van a ser sándwich aquí
está la prueba
usando trigonometría básica y el teorema
del sándwich de como el límite cuando x
se aproxima 0 de seno de x / x va a ser
igual a 1